welcome back to New rockstars I'm Hector
Navarro and today I want to talk about
some recent conversations happening
online discussing what the DC
entertainment brand based on DC Comics
actually is we just had a great DC film
hit theaters and it's not making quite
as much money as us fans of the movie
would have hoped it's a bit lighter it's
family friendly it's family oriented and
the internet's talking about whether or
not Blue Beetle is actually
representative of DC the brand or if the
movie was just chasing the Marvel Brand
which has been talked about as being
lighter more comedic more kid-friendly
and Disney fied so is DC only at its
best when it's dark will audiences
accept any lighter more
all-ages-friendly stories in the DC
Universe in an effort to try and
actually answer this question I went
down a bit of a rabbit hole and at the
end I found myself at the source the
comic books themselves it's basically
impossible to narrow down all of comic
book history to one comic that can help
answer this question and I'm sure you
can point to various Comics to try and
make your case one way or the other but
what about the specific comic published
by both Marvel and see together that
delivers a superhero story that actually
Compares contrasts and kind of defines
what each of these universes or Brands
actually are I'm talking about JLA
Avengers or Avengers JLA depending on
which issue you're reading the four
issue groundbreaking genre defining
comic book miniseries that came out 20
years ago next month in September of
2003 from writer Kurt Busick and the
greatest comic book artist of all time
and I'm not going to hear anything
otherwise George Perez this is it right
here ooh this is older than some of you
people watching right now
this book features the Justice League
from the DC Universe meeting and
interacting with the Avengers from the
Marvel Universe and getting involved in
an epic Cosmic story that even gave us
meta commentary on what those universes
stand for and what the stories do so I'm
gonna provide some context for that
story highlight some favorite moments
and talk about the differences and
similarities between Marvel and DC to
really get to the bottom of is DC
actually just dark we're gonna find out
but before I do just a real quick
reminder that new rockstars is now three
channels this main one the break room
and the Deep dive so make sure you're
subscribed to all three in case we
explore this topic further across the
new rock stars verse Isn't that cool
Rockstar's verse I coined that there's
actually a really fun history of DC and
Marvel doing comic book crossovers that
could be its own video but Avengers JLA
which stands for Justice League of
America is I think the perfect example
for this particular topic because it
shows us characters from the two
universes actually comparing their
realities or brands with one another in
JLA Avengers part 1 in the Marvel
Universe we see the Grand Master as he's
rudely interrupted by a cosmic presence
From Another Universe DC character
Corona the main villain of this series
and he will not be denied a month later
the Justice League are fighting off
Marvel villain Terminus the ravager of
Worlds at a shopping mall in Iowa and we
really get to see how effective the JL
is as a fighting unit telepathically
linked by Martian Manhunter and
commanded by Master strategist in the
field Batman it's awesome then at the
same time in the Marvel Universe The
Avengers are fighting off staro the
Conqueror in New York City and we see
how the Avengers work as a fighting unit
the team's plan to defeat staro involves
letting the Scarlet Witch interface with
the cosmic starfish and use her chaos
magic to disrupt the Extraterrestrial
beings ordered controlling mind and the
Avengers make starro Scream It's badass
in the DC Universe The Flash is running
experiments with the JL to try and match
the vibrational frequency of terminus's
Home reality to assess the threat and he
succeeds popping over into the Marvel
Universe and meeting a teen mutant being
chased by a bigoted angry mob one of the
cornerstones of the Marvel Universe are
the X-Men stories that directly take on
themes of racism social inequality and
how marginalized groups survive in
hostile environments things that
characters like the flash don't usually
deal with so here he's really surprised
that this mob is acting like this and
doubling down after assuming he's a
mutant too back home in the DC Universe
Grandmaster appears at the Justice
League's Watchtower moon base and
explains everything confirmed by Wonder
Woman's golden lasso of Gaia Grandmaster
tells the Justice League that their
universe will die unless 12 items of
Power Six from each Universe are
assembled and that's the plot after
telling the heroes that there will be
others seeking them Grand Master exits
and the league agrees he can't be
trusted but they're going to investigate
anyway then the Justice League traveled
to the Marvel Universe the league are
doing reconnaissance observing and
Reporting not getting involved Aquaman
sees ruthless Monarch Dr Doom and
latvaria but Batman tells them not to
get involved Martian Manhunter Witnesses
the devastation and genocide of mutants
in general but Batman tells him not to
get involved Superman sees destruction
caused by the Hulk in Michigan but
Batman tells him not to get involved and
finally Batman sees the Punisher in New
York murdering drug dealers but uh wait
a minute this is Batman we're talking
about of course he gets involved we cut
to a Plastic Man berating bats for
taking 20 minutes to beat the out
of Frank Castle and all the Justice
League agree that this world is Bleak
Superman goes on a rant about how this
world's Heroes have allowed this and
accuses them of not caring it's really
interesting to see how DC's Heroes
respond to the state of the Marvel
Universe and it makes sense that the
Justice League especially Superman would
feel this way after showing up and
sending the Justice League back to their
native reality The Avengers meet the
greatest mind of new genesis Metron who
explains they need to fight the Justice
League prevent them from Gathering 12
items of power or else their universe
will die again that's the plot before
Metron disappears he gives the Avengers
a mother box so they can travel to the
DC Universe The Avengers then arrive in
a futuristic metropolis and take down
some bankrupt robbers then get mobbed by
grateful bystanders who want autographs
Captain America reminds the team they've
got a mission to do and the Avengers see
how much this world loves and honors its
Heroes how much the public idolizes
their Heroes mutant Quicksilver learns
they have a museum dedicated to their
super Speedster The Flash an entire
Museum just the exact opposite
experience the flash had when he visited
the Marvel Universe cap goes on a rant
accusing this world's Heroes of building
their own advanced cities acting like
little tin Gods demanding The public's
adoration instead of protecting its
freedoms again a really fascinating take
on how Marvel's heroes would react to
the differences in the DC Universe and
as Steve Rogers whose origin dealt with
fighting fascists in World War II would
feel about a universe where Heroes have
really helped shape the human world
around them and then part one ends with
the Justice League showing up Superman
accusing the Avengers of being loose
cannons and cap accusing the league of
being fascist overlords and the sound of
mjolnir cracking against a man of
Steel's face signaling the beginning of
the fight between the Avengers and the
Justice League oh man do I love me some
comic books so we got some great
contrasting between the ideals the
Justice League and the DC Universe
represent versus the more flawed and
challenging Marvel Universe filled with
bigotry genocide and street level
vigilantism now of course there are
exceptions within each brand to what I
just listed but generally speaking this
is one way to look at what the stories
from the Marvel and DC universes deal
with it's been very interesting how in
the movie World Marvel has taken on the
reputation of being light and
crowd-pleasing because of the MCU
following the template laid out by the
first Iron Man movie which at times felt
like an Indie comedy in the superhero
world back to the story in part two a
contest of Champions continues and we
see Avenger versus Justice League some
pretty awesome fights the fan favorite
though has to be Captain America versus
Batman where we learn that after they
feel each other out Batman admits that
the super soldier could beat him only
that it would take a very very long time
they team up instead to try to get to
the bottom of all of this
one shot energy huh okay I'll try it
[Applause]
whoa what is one shots Focus chew do
I can see it
turns
[Music]
wow one shot really is all you need
begin your transformation with one shot
energy today by going to
oneshotenergy.com new rockstars for 10
off your order the Justice League heads
back to the Marvel Universe and Superman
calls the people of that world backward
which is like the meanest thing
Superman's ever said he's pissed that a
statue of The Avengers has been defaced
and it's like yeah man this world is
full of people who hate and fear their
Heroes which is a stark contrast to what
Superman is mostly used to in the comics
Clark Kent has generally speaking had
faith that the people of Earth are good
and he's usually been proven right maybe
one reason audiences believe the DC
brand is always dark is because their
current movie franchise has been
following the groundwork led by 2013's
Man of Steel which showed us a really
conflicted Superman not knowing if the
people of Earth could be trusted if he
revealed himself as an alien and used
his powers to help humanity and a lot of
people connected with that take but the
issue is was it the best setup for the
rest of the DC brand and characters or
did it set them up for conflicting ideas
of what DC is Meanwhile Back in the
comics and back of the bat cave as Steve
Rogers looks at a costume display case
we see another similarity between Marvel
and DC both Captain America and Batman
have lost crime fighting Partners Bucky
and Rob and Jason Todd fun fact this was
two years before both of these former
Sidekicks would return to comics in 2005
as brain scrambled Villains The Winter
Soldier and the Red Hood and then one of
my favorite moments of the entire comic
Steve Rogers sends a homing Beacon back
to his reality so that the Fantastic
Forest thing can appear and gives our
heroes a way for them to jump around
Dimensions thing heads back home and
Batman makes a joke about him having a
rough-edged charm and cap defends The
Thing by saying he may not be sleek and
elegant like the heroes that Batman
works with but Benjamin J Grimm is one
of the finest men he knows it's a great
bit but it's also a perfect summary of
the more Rough Around the Edges Marvel
Heroes versus the Sleek elegant really
put together DC heroes I mean the DC
heroes are just very attractive I mean
so are the Avengers to be fair so are
the Avengers Aquaman speaking of
attractive Aquaman and later opines on
The Avengers saying that the heroes seem
less powerful in general than at home
and that their worlds stacked against
them Superman admits they may have to
fight harder than the Justice League do
but it still isn't enough and from
Superman's point of view he might be
right and I just have to mention another
awesome bit of geeky fan service we see
Darkseid with The Infinity Gauntlet what
could be the scariest thing in either
universe is deflated thankfully when we
learned the gauntlet doesn't work in a
universe outside of its native one which
we also saw in Loki season one and the
what if animated series okay so tensions
are rising between the heroes of the
Marvel and DC universes and in part
three things start to come together
literally we see a new history of these
universes where Marvel and DC have
always been crossing over and just how
many similarities there actually are
similar villains similar Traditions
similar Heroes with gimmicks and yeah
Green Arrow and Hawkeye have a really
great rivalry going on but it's just
dimensional glitches affecting both
realities Superman and Captain America
can sense something's wrong though and
they Let each other know it but Wonder
Woman shuts the argument down because
they're all heroes damn it and saving
both realities and all the people in
them is what's most important the WASP
agrees and the heroes realize that both
universes are being forced to merge
together then versions of our heroes
from across their own timelines like
Barry Allen Flash and Hal Jordan Green
Lantern unite to try and stop this
Universal merging eventually going back
to Grand Master who shows them what the
truth of each Universe actually is and
it's tragic years of Triumph and tragedy
glory and pain all moments from the
histories of the DC and Marvel universes
we see evil thwarted Nations fall
enemies Prosper friends die hope dashed
hope reborn love and anger and sacrifice
and Terror loss rebirth failure Fury
horror heartbreak death betrayal Madness
and what's fascinating here is is that
it's both universes Marvel and DC put up
right next to one another so yes they're
different they're unique but they're
both capable of going to some very dark
places with their superhero characters
and even after characters like Barry and
Hal see their untimely deaths and vision
and Wanda see the children they are
fated to lose they all still agree to
take the fight to villain Crona to save
both universes at the expense of their
own lives and happiness in part 4 our
heroes are so United that even the
Schism between Superman and Captain
America is no more Clark nominates cap
to be their commander who can lead both
teams Steve and Clark apologize to one
another and even confess their own
insecurities about doing too much or
doing too little on their worlds and
that's when Captain America gives
Superman his shield to wield then we
enter the battlefield and let me tell
you to hear Superman Batman Wonder Woman
and more yell Avengers Assemble why
that's just the greatest superhero fan
service ever made my friends Avengers
end game could never then we see nearly
every Marvel character every DC
character fighting nearly every Marvel
in DC villain all to make their way to
the big bad Crona in the salvation of
both universes sacrifice Triumph
everything we know these characters are
capable of it's what superhero comic
books are all about finally when Thor is
down for the count he throws mjolnir to
Superman who's worthy of lifting it when
the battle is won and reality is
restored Our Heroes Bid Farewell to each
other and sum up the DC and Marvel
Brands whether they fear they do too
much or not enough they keep trying this
is the difference between Marvel and DC
heroes who feel as though they do too
much or do too little but the underlying
aspect that both universes share is that
they have Heroes who put everything on
the line for the rest of their worlds
maybe DC isn't inherently dark but both
DC and Marvel Superheroes share tragedy
and Triumph in their stories adding to
that notion DC Comics have published
some of the greatest comics in history
like Watchmen or too many to list
vertigo titles but they're arguably not
part of the regular DC Universe of
superheroes and let's be honest the
undeniable gravitational power of Batman
seems to make all the rest of DC dark
even if he's the exception to the rule I
don't blame audiences for thinking DC is
at its best when it's darker because
there have been a ton of great Batman
movies made for example but there's
never really been like a good Plastic
Man movie made that's also really funny
and has real emotion and drama because
Plastic Man is a legit Great Character I
don't think it's controversial to say
that DC needs to build up enough
Goodwill for the studio to take a risk
like making a movie like Plastic Man and
then have that risk pay off if Marvel
worked up to that with Guardians of the
Galaxy and Ant-Man building up that
Goodwill then maybe James Gunn can bring
DC to that sort of Goodwill and risk
it's a shame that something is great and
special as Blue Beetle came out at a
time where audiences aren't fully on
board with the DC brand oh and also it
was released during a historic double
strike pay your writers and Actors
Studio heads just pay them come on we
all have our own personal connections to
these characters and the DC fandom is
pretty divided these days I hope it
won't always be that way I hope we can
come together like the heroes from two
universes and celebrate what we love
about DC after all these stories are
about Hope and heroism I want folks who
love darker DC material to continue
being excited and enthusiastic about DC
and I also want fans who love more
optimistic DC material to be stoked
about the future anyways thanks for
letting me tell you all about my
formative DC Marvel comic book the one
that made me love both universes and a
reminder to go read it yourself if
you're interested follow me over at
Heroes reforged on YouTube and we'll see
you next time bye
[Music]
foreign